you look very handsome thank you very
much I'm doing well but the question is
how are you it has been a turbulent week
for you this week not really I'm doing
well I'm here to celebrate the people
who are on the power list for time 100
so and I'm happy to be here are you yeah
there was no trepidation about coming
out this evening and hitting the carpet
no why not why would I why would I have
trepidation well do you have anything
that you would like to set the record
straight on in regards to your departure
from CNN this week no listen uh I am
happy to be moving in a New Direction
I'm going to miss all of the talented
people and journalists at CNN who are my
friends who I love and who I've been
speaking to all day but it's only been
like a day but it's felt like a week but
because it's been so many people have
been reaching out but no I'm I'm fine
life is good I've got my beautiful
fiance here and we're all good and what
is that new direction for you what do
you envision you doing here on moving
forward summer on the beach and on the
boat and chilling out with my family my
dogs and my fiance and it's going to be
great it's going to be a great summer
but Don we have seen you on television
for 17 plus years now I can't imagine
the man wants to get away from TV so are
you plotting what your next venture will
be you're making me feel old actually no
I'm not I'm plotting what I'm gonna do
for the summer it's I'm seriously if I
had something in mind I would totally
tell you but no I mean I'm just I'm just
chilling out and we'll see what happens
next one one day at a time and one foot
in front of the other in any regrets I
have no this is life you get one life I
have no regrets I live my life
virtually carefree and regret-free and
you can't change the past you can only
move into the future and live in the
present and that's what I'm doing what
was your reaction the same day as your
departure from CNN Tucker Carlson
departed from Fox News so much reactions
I wish Tucker Carlson all the best
foreign
[Music]